the supreme court has shut down one of
president trump's latest and last
attempts to overturn the election an
election he clearly lost in one short
sentence the court denied a republican
challenge
to the vote in pennsylvania ed o'keefe
is covering the biden transition in
wilmington delaware ed good morning to
you
the president-elect has a lot going on
these days but has he responded in any
way to this latest ruling
well good morning tony his campaign said
overnight that the election is over and
that mr biden will be sworn in as
president in january the president-elect
is
focusing instead on how to fight the
pandemic and laying out what exactly he
do about it
in his first 100 days masking
vaccinations opening schools
these are the three key goals for my
first 100 days
president-elect biden says he wants 100
million vaccines given to americans in
his first 100 days
that's the same number of vaccines
promised by the trump administration
but mr biden is warning that the
president's vaccination plan could fall
short without additional funding there's
a real chance
that after an early round of
vaccinations
the effort will slow and stall the
president-elect
also rolled out his health team
including dr anthony fauci
who will remain in his current role and
be chief medical advisor to mr biden
the road ahead will not be easy
fauci skipped a vaccine summit hosted by
president trump tuesday which featured
no representatives from vaccine
manufacturers
the president used the event to falsely
insist he won the election
hopefully the next administration will
be the trump administration
meanwhile mr biden continues to fill out
other parts of his cabinet
cbs news has learned he plans to
nominate ohio congresswoman marcia fudge
to run the department of housing and
urban development and tom vilsack is
agriculture secretary
the same job he held during the obama
administration
today the president-elect also plans to
introduce retired army general lloyd
austin as his pick for defense secretary
if confirmed he'd be the first black man
to lead the pentagon
but some democrats on capitol hill are
skeptical of austin's nomination
because he's been out of military
service for less than seven years
a federal law requires uniform
commanders to wait at least that long
before taking top civilian jobs at the
pentagon
austin would need congress to pass a
waiver exempting him
in an op-ed in the atlantic mr biden
said congress should do so as it did for
president trump's first defense
secretary
james mattis and mark morial president
of the national urban league
agrees my encouragement is
democrats and republicans here loud and
clear
don't impose a differential standard on
general austin
morial was one of the civil rights
leaders who met with the president-elect
last night to discuss his cabinet picks
and what he's going to be doing about
racial justice concerns now if you're
keeping score at home
at this point the president-elect has
appointed a dozen cabinet picks
eight of them are people of color six of
them are men
and gail six of them are women thank you
for the breakdown because a lot of
people at our keeping score
the white house has also weighed in on
those stimulus negotiations i know they
are
what what can you tell us about the
latest on that
yeah so the white house is injecting a
little bit of uncertainty into these
talks over that bipartisan plan that
would cost about 908 billion dollars in
exchange
for another round of six hundred dollar
stimulus checks the white house would
offer 40 billion dollars for federal
unemployment insurance that might sound
good but that's 140 billion dollars
less than what's in the bipartisan plan
that would help tens of millions of
jobless americans
democratic leaders are calling the
administration's proposal unacceptable
then there's the defense policy bill
usually this thing passes
without any controversy it lays out all
the different plans for the pentagon
for the forthcoming year but the
president is threatening a veto
last night however the house passed it
overwhelmingly with enough votes
to if necessary override a veto from the
president
which could come in the closing days of
his presidency
gail should all remember people really
need this money thank you very much ed